hello and I was going to say good
morning but good afternoon to wherever
in the world you are joining us from
today we're glad you can join us for our
live web webinar called impact those two
formulations of you burn or fiend on
post-surgical condition in mice my name
is Diane Ordonez from Columbia
University and I will be the moderator
for this session today's educational
webinar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning to learn more
visit lab roots com let's get started
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
still fresh in your mind
to do so simply type them into the Q&A
box which will open when you click the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered at the end of the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
you may click on the screen icon on the
lower right-hand of the slide window
should you experience any technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button that can be found on the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit
I now proudly present today's speaker
dr. Nicole Herndon who is a veterinarian
currently at Columbia University Medical
Center she obtained her doctorate of
Veterinary Medicine from Oregon State
University where she spent some time at
the Oregon National primate Center
including working in a Huntington's
disease research laboratory following
completion of veterinary school dr.
Herndon began a three-year post doctoral
research residency for veterinary
laboratory animal medicine at Columbia
University while in this role dr.
Herndon oversees the general animal care
in the facilities trains investigators
on aseptic technique and surgical skills
in rodent models performs veterinary
protocol review consultations is an
active participant in iaccoca meetings
and has participated in site visits from
the USDA Department of Health and ailich
she also assists with the anesthesia
monitoring of the USDA regulated species
she completed a research project
comparing mortality rates selected
inflammatory cytokines and overall
condition of mice administered beeper
and orphaned sustained relief to
buprenorphine hydrochloride in a mere I
model for polymicrobial sepsis the
results of which were published in the
Journal of comparative medicine in
December of 2016
she will complete her residency in June
of 2017 I now present dr. Herndon who
will begin her presentation Thank You
Diane and thank you all again for coming
and listening to this presentation today
the purpose of this presentation is to
discuss the use of two formulations of
ebin orphan standard buprenorphine or
buprenorphine hydrochloride and
sustained release paper nor Fein
specifically in regards to surgical
models in mice will cover the analgesic
effects of each formulation compare the
two in terms of analgesic effects and
finally and covering a study that
compared the two formulations in a
murine sepsis model the learning
objectives for this presentation are to
identify the benefits and disadvantages
of the use of buprenorphine HCl and
sustain release in a murine model also
you should be able to describe methods
to evaluate post surgical condition in
mice for starters why do we need to
consider the use of analgesics in our
animal studies aside from ethical
considerations there are several
regulatory bodies that require the use
of analgesics and animal procedures the
health research extension Act of 1985
states that unless the contrary is known
or established it should be considered
that procedures that cause pain in
humans they also cause pain in other
animals
the government principles for the
utilization and care of vertebrate
animals used in testing research and
training state sub procedures with
animals that may cause more than
momentary or slight pain or distress
should be performed with appropriate
sedation analgesia or anesthesia the PHS
policy states that animals used in
biomedical and behavioral research are
provided with appropriate treatment
including the appropriate use of
tranquilizers analgesics and post
surgical veterinary medical and nursing
care now that we've established the need
to consider the use of pain medications
in our studies what analgesic options do
we have listed here are some common
analgesic agents that we see used in
mice non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs or NSAIDs such as carprofen are
often used because of their ability to
alleviate inflammatory types of pain
they tend to have a longer duration of
action than opioids thereby requiring
less frequent dosing some of the side
effects of non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs are gastric or
intestinal ulceration disturbance of
platelet function and changes in renal
function opioids are used following
procedures that are thought to cause
more severe pain necessitating the use
of a more potent analgesia this is
especially true when there is a chance
of deep or visceral pain stimulated
during the procedure
since this presentation is focusing on
buprenorphine we're going to delve into
this energy look properties a little bit
further deeper nor fien is a partial
knee agonist and kappa antagonist it has
a lower abuse potential compared to
other opioids which may be in part due
to a ceiling affected buprenorphine
increasing the dose of buprenorphine
will increase its effect up to a ceiling
at which point the antagonistic
properties predominate and begin to
decrease the analgesic efficacy it has a
relatively long duration of action
compared to other opioids as well some
of the noted side effects would be
our theme our pika respiratory
depressions
decreased intestinal activity decreased
heart rate and sedation there's been
considerable data available on the
dosage and efficacy of buprenorphine
sustained-release buprenorphine or beef
nor Fein SR it's a sustained release
injectable formulation of buprenorphine
that was developed by a United States
veterinary compounding pharmacy there
have been a number of studies that
examined the duration of action of us
are compared with buprenorphine HCl
we'll cover a few such studies now this
paper from 2012 was written by Carbone
and colleagues had a duration of action
of sustained release buprenorphine in
two strains of mice this study used the
hotplate assay to assess the anti no CSF
2 effects of a single injection of
buprenorphine sustained-release
buprenorphine HCL and saline over 72
hours and young adult Bobbsey and SW RJ
mice this graph represents the maximum
possible effect on the y-axis and time
on the x axis this group notice a
significant difference between
buprenorphine HCl and buprenorphine SR
and the control at two hours highlighted
here between beef SR and Saline at 6
hours and 12 hours and also notice the
difference between buprenorphine SR and
buprenorphine HCl at 72 hours
what this study concluded was that there
was a significant or a relative increase
from baseline latency significant per
pupil nor féin HCR SR my apologies at
two six and 12 hours the analgesic
efficacy a few SR lasted at least 12
hours in the mail Bobbsey and SWR mi the
next study we'll look at is from 2014
from Kendall and colleagues titled
pharmacokinetics of sustained release
analgesics in mice this study looked to
determine the pharmacokinetics of
sustained release formulations of paper
nor Fein carprofen the torsional
Sentinel and meloxicam compared with the
standard formulations of buprenorphine
carprofen and meloxicam mice were
divided into treatment groups and dosed
the analgesic for that particular group
the plasma concentrations of the group
are listed at least charts here
significant differences were noted in
buprenorphine SR and sustained and HCl
at four hours eight hours and they
noticed a significant difference between
carprofen SR and stand a release
carprofen
at four hours finally from meloxicam the
group noticed a significant difference
at two hours four hours and eight hours
between the standard the sustained
release and the standard formulation
specifically for the beeper nor Fein
doses this group found that
buprenorphine s are plasma drug levels
were greater than the therapeutic level
for the first 24 to 48 hours
also plasma levels of beep HCl fell
below the therapeutic level by 4 hours
finally these results indicated that
buprenorphine s are provided a stable
plasma drug level adequate for analgesia
for 24 to 48 hours after administration
whereas all other sustained-release
formulations required additional doses
to provide analgesic levels beyond 24
hours in mice the last study will look
at comparing the pharmacokinetic
assessment of standard or sustained
release paper nor Fein is from 2014 by
Clark and colleagues titled
pharmacokinetic comparison a sustained
release and standard buprenorphine in
mice this study compared different
dosages for animals in either standard
buprenorphine or sustained release
formulation as well as a saline control
group male c57 black 6 mice were
provided with buprenorphine HCl in this
table labeled bewp I are standing for
immediate relief and bewp SR at the
doses listed at the table the people in
our phenyl aiesec it was used to
determine the drug concentration in the
blood samples this grass plots the
buprenorphine concentration in blood of
the different buprenorphine formulations
over 48 hours the upper horizontal
dashed line represents the therapeutic
threshold for buprenorphine
this study concluded that buprenorphine
SR at one point 2 milligrams per
kilogram imbued HCL at 0.1 or 2
milligrams per kilogram achieved or
surpassed the published threshold for
adequate analgesia in life in addition
as the previous chart showed 1.2
milligram per kilogram buprenorphine SR
and 2 milligram per kilogram P burn or
Fein HCl provided blood concentrations
above therapeutic threshold for up to 12
hours now that we've established that
buprenorphine SR has the
pharmacokinetics to last for an extended
duration of time let's look at some of
the studies that compared a bewp HCl to
beef SR for pain relief this study was
published in 2014 by heel Healey and
colleagues and was titled evaluation of
an improved sustained release
buprenorphine formulation for the use in
mice mice were assigned to three
treatment groups a control a dosing of
buprenorphine HCl or no dose of
buprenorphine SR mice were evaluated to
determine behavioral and physiological
responses at for 24 and 48 hours after
treatment administration the mice were
evaluated for total activity
gastrointestinal tract motility
respiratory rate cataleptic behavior
tail flick and hot plate nose the
Assumption test and body weights what he
leaked and colleagues concluded was that
buprenorphine s are maintained anti no
Co septic effects for 48 hours for the
hot plate and tail flick test the
buprenorphine s our group had a lower
respiratory rate compared to the control
group buprenorphine SR had no
significant changes in body weight
during the study whereas buprenorphine
HCl mice had a significant decrease in
body
wait at 24 and 48 hours in terms of the
other parameters evaluated the
gastrointestinal tract motility and
total activity were higher at four hours
four mice receiving the buprenorphine s
are that per mice receiving the vehicle
but the values were the same between the
groups at 24 and 48 hours this 2015
paper by jerkov at and colleagues titled
buprenorphine for pain relief in mice
repeated injections versus sustained
release the poe formulation sought to
compare the sustained release
formulation of buprenorphine with a
standard protocol of three injections of
b4 nor Fein in female mice undergoing a
laparotomy procedure female c57 black 6
mice underwent a one-sided sham embryo
transfer for their surgery the following
methods were used to test the analgesic
efficacy serum concentrations of
buprenorphine thermal sensitivity using
a hot plate and ethological measures of
pain and recovery including body weight
food and water intake brewing behavior
and an ether gram score an ether gram is
a catalog or table of all the different
kinds of behavior or activity observed
in an animal ether grants have been
described from many species and the one
shown here is specific for mice by
assigning numeric values to the scores a
scoring system can be established in
efforts to provide more objectiveness to
a subjective situation this particular
ether Graham I used was used by jerk-off
and colleagues to quantitatively
evaluate the clinical condition of their
mice jerk-offs and colleagues found that
the mice dosed with bewp HCl had serum
concentrations and thermal sensitivity
tests for a duration of at least four
hours but less than eight hours the
animals dosed with the buprenorphine s
are
duration of action of 24 to 48 hours
behavioral and clinical parameters
indicated at least partial pain relief
after surgery for both protocols this
group indicated that an application
interval of 8 hours for buprenorphine
HCl appeared too long and might lead to
repeated periods with insufficient and
loggia and animals undergoing lasting or
substantial pain after surgery in
comparison to the standard protocol the
buprenorphine s are provided a long
lasting assured analgesia without
possible stressful repeated injections
in a standard surgical model with only
limited and acceptable behavioral side
effects
the next study came out in 2016 by
Kendall and colleagues it's titled
efficacy a sustained release
buprenorphine in an experimental
laparotomy model in female mice this
group thought to determine the clinical
efficacy of ups are at zero point six
milligrams per kilogram for 72 hours
after an experimental laparotomy in
female
cd1 my female cd1 life mm-hmm underwent
laparotomy procedure and received either
buprenorphine SR just as zero point six
milligrams per kilogram P burn or Fein
HCl just at 0.1 milligram per kilogram
every 12 hours or saline given it every
12 hours pain was assessed of varying
time points according to the frequency
of several behaviors these behaviors
included general activity wheel running
activity rearing behavior grooming wound
licking percentage of integrated nest
material body wave and orbital
tightening
orbital tightening is one of the
components of a mouse grimace scale
system described by Langford at all
orbital tightening is the narrowing of
the orbital area with a tightly closed
eyelid for an eye squeeze noticed by
wrinkling around the eye this figure on
this slide here comes from the Langford
paper titled coating a facial expression
of pain in the laboratory mice while
Kendall and colleagues did not utilize a
full Mouse grimace scale system as
described by Langford they were able to
isolate a component of the scoring
system to better evaluate the
post-operative pain in their mind going
back one slide to discuss the other
parameters of the group measured the
wheel running activity was node to be
increased in wound licking decrease over
time in my summer dose with
buprenorphine SR compared to my snow
swith buprenorphine HCl and the Saline
control mice buprenorphine sr mice had
an increased general activity and
percentage of integrated nests material
as well as decreased orbital tightening
for 1 to 6 hours after surgery compared
with the buprenorphine HCL and the
Saline treated mice in general to
buprenorphine HCL and saline treated
mice had general similar general
activity orbital tightening scores and
wheel running activity
from their results Kendall and
colleagues concluded that buprenorphine
SR at a dose of 0.6 milligrams per
kilogram provides adequate analgesia
after laparotomy in mice buprenorphine
HCl at a dose of 0.1 milligram per
kilogram every 12 hours may be
inadequate for providing analgesia for
abdominal procedures in mice the
previous studies we covered were able to
compare pain relief of buprenorphine HCl
and buprenorphine SR however there have
been fewer studies examining how
buprenorphine SR may have an effect on
different research parameters the next
paper attempted to compare the effects
of bewp SR and view of HCL in a commonly
used research model in mice this
research titled sustained release
buprenorphine improves post-surgical
clinical condition but does not alter
survival or cytokine levels in a urine
model of polymicrobial sepsis was
conducted by myself and colleagues with
the goal to determine the effects of
buprenorphine HCl compared with
buprenorphine SR on several parameters
in mice undergoing a sequel ligation and
perforation procedure clinical condition
plasma concentrations of monocyte
chemoattractant protein 1 and
interleukin 6 and overall mortality were
measured in efforts to concern the post
surgical condition in these mice
male c57 black 6 mice underwent a CLP
surgery performed by the same surgeon
who was blinded to all treatment groups
mortality was recorded at every time
point mice were examined inflammatory
cytokine levels were measured at 24
hours post CLP procedure mice were
observed twice daily for the clinical
condition scoring by the same blinded
investigator the evaluation of the post
surgical condition consisted of an ether
gram the parameters consisting of
movement posture interaction with
conspecifics response to cage opening in
response to handling the time to
integrate two nests test was also
performed on all animals undergoing the
CLP procedure
finally nest scoring was performed every
day post CLP procedure this figure comes
from a Gaskell and colleagues paper
titled nest building as an indicator of
health and welfare in laboratory mice
and represents a standard and a scoring
system the standard nest scoring system
is on a scale of 0 to 5 a score of zero
represents an untouched nesting material
a score of 1 represents the nesting
material is spread throughout the cage
with no discernible nest site a score of
2 is that the nest material has been
made flat with no shallow walls a score
of 3 is a slightly cup shaped nest where
the wall are less than half the height
of the dome a score of 4 is a wall that
is half the height of the dome and a
score of 5 our walls that are taller
than half the height of the dome which
may or may not fully enclose the nest
the results of this paper show that
there was no significant difference in
the cytokine levels MCP one or il-6
there was also no significant difference
in the mortality between the animals
dosed with people nor Fein HCl or
buprenorphine SR there was a significant
decrease in the behaviors associated
with perceived pain at 12 and 24 hours
postoperatively in the mice in the
buprenorphine fr group compared with the
buprenorphine HCl group neither group
was noted to build nests fall in the
procedure and neither group were tint
positive during this testing this is a
visual representation of the
inflammatory cytokine serum levels and
at the mortality curve noted in this
study as previously indicated in the
here in Figure a the mzp-1 levels showed
no significant difference between the
bewp HCl and the view press our mice
figure B shows the il-6 serum
concentration levels and again there was
no significant difference between the
bewp HCl for the buprenorphine sr mice
as previously stated there was no
significant difference in either
mortality between the two groups
this is a representation of the clinical
condition scoring with the ether gram
results displayed here figure a so the
clinical condition scoring twelve hours
post CLP procedure there was
significantly fewer proceeded behaviors
of pain at twelve hours as noted in this
chart figure B shows the clinical
condition scoring at 24 hours
post CLP procedure and again there was a
significant there were significantly
fewer perceived behaviors of pain at
this time in the buprenorphine s our
group compared with the buprenorphine
HCl group figure C represents the
clinical condition scoring at 36 hours
post CLP procedure at 36 hours the
condition scores were not significantly
different between the two groups because
of the lack of significant effect on MC
p1 and il-6 levels and the mortality or
the mortality and the superior analgesic
effects with buprenorphine SR my
colleagues and I recommend the use of
buprenorphine SR for analgesia during
the Murai and CLP model of sepsis also
due to the clinical condition of animals
in the buprenorphine HCl group we
recommend more frequent dosing than
every 12 hours for animals undergoing a
CLP model of sepsis
this slide provides a generalized
outline of some of the benefits and
disadvantages of the use of people nor
Fein HCl and buprenorphine SR as a
studies we found over have indicated
there is a need for more frequent dosing
with the buprenorphine HCl compared to
that of the pupae nor Fein SR this means
that researchers would be able to
physically see their animals at the
times of buprenorphine HCl
administration which could be more
frequent than those animals dosed with
buprenorphine SR although not mentioned
specifically in this discussion there
are more studies that show buprenorphine
has little effect on some parameters of
research such as inflammatory cytokines
such expensive research is not yet
available for buprenorphine SR at this
time I see studies have shown
buprenorphine SR has reported analgesic
effects lasting greater than 12 hours
this equates to less frequent handling
and potentially less stressed caused to
animals from the increased injections
required with buprenorphine HCl in
general some side effects of opioids
include weight loss and pica as well as
increased lethargy or sedation this
increased lethargy and sedation has
shown to have an effect on the scoring
of Ness as well as tint scoring in some
studies and should be considered when
evaluating post-operative pain in mice
so what should we expect to see in the
future in regards to sustained release
formulation of buprenorphine I would
expect to see more studies examining the
effects with other common research
procedures as well as studying the
effects on other animal species as other
standard release formulations come out
pharmacokinetic studies as well as
studies on effects and research are
expected to be seen I would like to say
thank you to the Columbia University
Medical Center as well as the lab
members who helped me with my paper
Sheila ban do pad hey Kevin Pristina and
Eldad Hall I'd like to also thank Dian
Ordonez again for being the moderator
for this presentation and I would like
to thank lab roots for giving me the
opportunity to speak about buprenorphine
SR as well as HCl in a post surgical
condition in mice these are my
references so feel free to use those and
when looking at the different view
preneur formulation and at this time I'd
like to open up the floor for any sort
of questions or discussion well thank
you very much dr. Herndon for your
presentation and just a quick reminder
for our audience on how to submit
questions should any of any strike you
simply type them in the Q&A box again
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and dr. Herndon will
answer as many questions as time permits
so the first question we have here is
have you noticed you pests are causing
wounds at the injection site in my
particular study we did not notice any
wounds at the injection site and I know
that in one of the other studies
mentioned they did not notice any gross
wounds at the injection site as well I
know in other species that has been one
of the concerns but in the mice models
that I have used I have not noticed any
injection site reactions
okay in your studies in particular we're
both HCl and SR given every 12 hours and
if so for how long and I believe it's in
reference to the duration of days right
so that's a good question for the HCL we
dosed every 6 to 12 hours as that
followed the pre-approved I cooked
protocol we were following so for the
initial two days we gave for the initial
24 hours we gave a dose every six hours
and then we waited 12 hours to the
following day and they did another every
six hour dosing for a total of six doses
over two days the SR was just given once
at the start of the procedure and yeah
that was the extent of the dosing that
we gave for our buprenorphine HCl and
buprenorphine SR okay and did you notice
a time difference between the analgesic
effect between the SR formulation versus
the hydrochloric formulation so the big
and on G like effect we saw was that
overnight time span so the doses were
given if I were to give an actual time
line the HC I was given at time of
surgery so 7:00 or 8:00 o'clock a.m. and
then again at noon or 1:00 and then
again at 6:00 or 7:00 and then we went
overnight to go and give another dose at
7:00 a.m. which was the 12 hours that
was probably the biggest effect that we
saw was that 12 hours spent between the
HCL and the SR dosing by 48 hours we had
reached a 50% mortality in our subsys
models which was to be expected and at
that point we didn't notice any
difference in the analgesic because our
mice had started to succumb to the
septic State that we and had induced
okay have you noticed any incidents of
pika and the mice under bewp SR and to
take that in conjunction with another
question have you are you aware of any
reports of the pika in mice versus rats
with the SR formulation if you're aware
of any of the literature knowledgeable
about that region or area so in our
study we did not notice any pika in the
mice that were dosed with people nor
Fein SR I don't recall seeing Pico
listed in SR and other research models
but I haven't seen all the research I'm
sure but I have not come across that I'm
sorry what was the second part of that
question again the second part of the
question that was posed was whether or
not you've noticed or if you came across
any articles related to peek of the SR
formulation and mice versus rat
I have not looked into SR and rat as
extensively as the mice so I don't have
an answer for that particular question
I'm sorry
our next question is whether or not
there have been studies looking to other
analgesic agents aside from
buprenorphine specifically in sepsis
studies there have been studies that
look at other analgesics in sepsis
studies there's been studies looking at
tramadol as well as some other
analgesics that I'm not quite familiar
with at this time but for the most part
of these studies that I've researched
the buprenorphine seem to have the most
minimal effect on sepsis studies in
regards to mortality and inflammatory
cytokines that were looked at and in
your opinion do you feel that that was
adequate analgesic coverage the
buprenorphine alone personally I feel
that if the buprenorphine was given at a
more frequent dosing so not going beyond
I would probably say six or yeah six to
eight hours it would be it would suffice
for the sepsis studies it just needs to
make sure that we give it frequently
enough so that the concentrations of
buprenorphine stay in the system so the
animals don't become painful hey can I
have just a few more questions here I'm
trying to consolidate them into one
question and it looks like this one
isn't directly related to the analgesia
regimen that was employed or talked
about in this presentation but more
related to the animal model that you
used so the question posed is what
methods have you used to confirm the
animal disease model so I believe this
is in reference and please correct me if
I'm wrong to the sequel ligation and
puncture and perforation model itself
I'm sorry can you repeat the question so
the question is what methods have you
used for confirmation of animal disease
model and from the way I interpret it in
the way that I'm reading it it's C
that the question posed is how did you
come what methods have you used to
confirm that CLP is more or less as the
literature would state the gold standard
of polymicrobial sepsis so the CLP study
has been performed for a number of years
and has improved in other studies as the
gold the gold standard model for sepsis
research there's other studies that are
recommend an injectable form where you
would actually inject bacteria into the
intra peritoneal space to induce a
septic State both of those models are
very common in literature I think the
main thing is not just historical but
there have been other studies
specifically done to prove that this is
a gold standard model of sepsis I
personally did not perform any other
models for sepsis okay thank you and it
looks like I'm getting the Trickle oh no
I have other questions just a second
have you used transgenic mice models
when comparing beef SR to HCA to the
regular buprenorphine personally I have
not and it's something I would go ahead
and look into other literature for we
were focusing mostly on what another lab
was using and we were using their models
in order to study the sepsis and the
best analgesic we could provide for
these mice and have you could you
comment just briefly on the efficacy of
the dosage that you used in this study
or in your particular study let me pull
that up the dosage that I used sorry as
I pulled that up
it was efficacious the animals looked
had much better clinical condition
scores versus the animals that were
given the buprenorphine HCl and we gave
a dose of one milligram per kilogram
subcutaneously
and actually as a follow-up to that this
is a very nice question are there other
ways to see that an animal has moderate
pain or not aside from the the
behavioral scoring that you performed in
your studying so behavioral scoring is
becoming bigger and bigger so that is a
really good way to assess their their
pain other ways that people there's
other ether gram scores out there
assess different parameters so one of
the papers I mentioned here included a
rearing behavior so being able to stand
up on their hind limbs wheel running
activity and one of the other big ones
that are out there are either the
building of the nest so doing a nest
scoring or the tent scoring which I
briefly mentioned and I didn't go into
great detail here but that's basically
where you have an animal that's already
built a nest a good nest and then you
add a portion or nesting material to the
opposite side of where that nest is and
you see if they incorporate that portion
of nests that you've added to their home
nest within I think a 10 minute time
span and if they do that it means that
they're of a more normal sense it's a
binary scoring system but those that's
one of the bigger ways this nest scoring
some people will also do weight loss or
food and water consumption just note
that if you're doing a surgical model
that animals may lose weight due to
surgery and not necessarily due to pain
and I just probably other methods out
there but those are the big ones that I
can that I can think of excellent and
this last question that I have here is
more of not a theoretical question or
maybe in your experience I know earlier
you alluded to not having performed work
in transgenic mice but this particular
question refers to whether or not you
would anticipate seeing differences in
analgesic efficacy
in different mouth streams so there have
been different studies that we mentioned
here today that use different strains
such as bob steam ice or the black six
mice or CD one and of those studies a
lot of them reported very similar
findings in that the efficacy the SR
seemed to work well it's one of those
questions that you'll never know until
you find one strain that is different
but for the most part you may see some
minor effects but hopefully the opioids
would be able to cover any sort of
significant procedures that may cause
significant pain a our next question you
are quite popular today dr. Herndon what
is your opinion on giving buprenorphine
prior to the first incision versus
giving it at the time of incision
closure I I recommend giving the
buprenorphine prior to the incision
the reason being you want to prevent any
sort of pain and the animals and any
sort of wind up pain that could occur by
giving the buprenorphine earlier you
give or any analgesic you give that
analgesic time to take effect prior to
causing any sort of painful stimuli in
my particular procedure we did give the
buprenorphine prior to the first
incision
we used again this is particular to my
study we used ISO fluorine so the
animals woke up quite quickly from the
end of their study and giving the pain
medication at the time of closure
wouldn't have allowed the buprenorphine
to have any time to take effect prior to
already causing the painful stimuli of
the surgery so I always recommend giving
an analgesic prior to making an incision
in mice and great thank you so much for
your responses to all of those questions
I don't have anymore questions here in
this queue and if there are no more I
would like to once again thank you well
sorry
nope not thanking you yet one more
question in your opinion do you could
you please comment on whether the use of
non opiates are efficient in terms of
providing analgesic relief and again I
think this is within the context of the
surgical model that you used I'll start
financing in general nonsteroidal
antiinflammatory x' or other non opioid
drugs can be efficient you really have
to consider the surgical model that
you're doing and the type of pain that
you may be inducing so as I had stated a
little bit earlier non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs are really good
for inflammatory types of pain so just
an incisional pain or something that's
more of a minor procedure non opioid
drugs would cover that sort of procedure
when you start getting into deeper or
more of a visceral pain the example
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs I
don't feel are sufficient and on the
urban studies showing that more potent
analgesia isn't it is needed for some of
those more intensive surgeries so it
really depends on what your surgery is
for my study anecdotally speaking the
lab I was working with had felt that the
animals displayed more painful signs
when they weren't using an opioid drug
so they were very adamant on using a
type of opioid to try to alleviate as
much pain as possible in that particular
sepsis model well said
now if there are no more further
questions I'd like to thank you once
again for your presentation did you have
any final comments I just want to thank
you all again especially if anyone's on
the west coast of the States thanks for
waking up and listening to a talk on
buprenorphine but thank you to everyone
who stuck around and listened and thank
you to the audience for joining us today
as dr. Herndon mention and for all of
your very interesting questions I am
having a few more trickles and we still
have a little bit of time dr. Herndon
would you like to take them sure okay
I have two more here and I'm going to
have to perhaps cap it after these two
questions if there are any other
questions please try to get them in the
next three to four minutes or so the
first of this next set of two questions
is how do you feel about giving
ketoprofen and buprenorphine in
conjunction so I'm assuming this is for
the sepsis studies I think was I think I
would agree with you we are going to
interpret it as within the within the
constraints of the surgical model
employed so with ketoprofen they're
having studies that show that some
anti-inflammatories do have an effect on
sepsis studies and because a lot of
stuffs of studies are looking at
anti-inflammatory cytokines by giving a
non-story an anti-inflammatory drug you
could easily affect those parameters so
for that there's been a lot of
literature really against the use of
anti-inflammatory medications in that
particular study in other studies again
you have to consider what your surgical
model is and see if that would have an
effect on what the study is trying to
prove
okay and I have another one in your
opinion or experience have you noted a
link between buprenorphine and self
trauma in my experience I have not most
of the studies that I looked at also if
they were looking specifically at wounds
licking the mean time that you'll see
wound trauma is initially after the
surgery and I mean this is completely my
opinion but an animal that recently had
surgery if there's any sort of residual
antiseptic there or if you used say
wound clips or surgical glue or sutures
it's new and the animal is going to be
interested in it and so there is a
little bit of attention paid to the
wound site after surgery regardless of
what analgesic you give however after
the initial interest in the wound site I
have not noticed any increase of wound
attention or attention paid towards the
wounds using buprenorphine excellent and
then my last question here which I think
will be the last question of this this
session is not in relation to the
surgical model you employed but to
another surgical model and it's more
geared towards general analgesics as a
whole what analgesic would you recommend
for stereotactic surgeries okay so
stereotaxic work which is always
interesting so if I'd seen the things
that I've seen most commonly employed
that seemed to work for the researchers
here giving a local analgesic so giving
something like pubic pain or lidocaine
prior to making an incision if they're
actually going to make an incision over
these over the scalp and I've also seen
the use of non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs like carprofen
as well as people nor Fein in
conjunction and that seems that
multimodal analgesia seems to really
help out the animals that are undergoing
stereotaxic where
excellent
that is it of all of our questions I'm
capping it now again thank you and thank
you to the audience for creating a
generous discussion I'd also like to
thank lab roots today for our
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through May of this
year lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's events I'll see you next time
here at lab roots com goodbye and be
well